hi my name is Ryan I've been a
substitute teacher for two years I'm
also a tutor for the SAT and for the AC
T my name is Mandy I am a former teacher
I taught for six years a wide variety of
subjects but one of them was English
which is why today I am grading
celebrity tweets so the first thing that
I'm gonna grade is actually this hall
pass it says hot on it and that is just
misspelled although I do like the
creativity not a fan okay so the first
one we have is from the Biebs and he
says I love arm I get a Justin Bieber
there's some nice arms out there but
unless you're talking about one specific
arm or maybe a person named arm I don't
know that might make it more
grammatically correct I mean I would
just capitalize that I put a period and
I mean I wonder what's going on in his
life that made him say that but that's
not terrible I guess I'm gonna say we're
gonna go I love arms I think that's what
he meant he might have just made me too
you know so we're gonna give him I'll
give him a b-plus just because I think
he can do better I would say I love arms
they're handy I'd give him a C because
it looks like you fell asleep maybe in
the middle of that a little nice X who
in New York and want to have a crying
contest we're missing some capitals here
right this needs an apostrophe s at the
end because the apostrophe has two jobs
either creates a contraction or it shows
possession I don't understand whenever I
see people who are typing things in it's
all lowercase I want to know what
they're using because I feel like you
have to actually make an effort for that
to not be capitalized because my
autocorrect does seems like an
interesting thing for a rapper to want
to have a contest about but at least
he's in touch with his inner you know
his emotions not a lot of men are these
days so you know what because of that
I'm gonna give him B - I'm feeling nice
today and then I'll just do that
I'll give them a B cardi B oh boy cardi
B this is gonna be interesting
I wish I can chew on my toenails but I
ain't that flexible no more they look
really tasty
licky face don't want to grade this like
it's English so much as I want to judge
her for this desire of hers I love the
use of emojis but the one problem that I
have here don't want to be a stickler
but this period this
loading period here is confusing me she
went on toenails you do what you want
cardi B here's the issue that I have
here right can means that you can do
something so you wouldn't need to wish
because you can do it right
cardi B come on you're better than that
you wish that you could chew on your
toenails
I'm gonna have to fail her on this one
just because that's so gross so you know
what cardi I love you
we're going C plus o poor share share
tweets oh this is old 2012 what's going
on with my career well I'll tell you
what share you forgot that they're
supposed to be spaces between words I
thought that especially when I was a
teacher
quite a bit we're also missing an
apostrophe here come on share this is a
question we're missing a space share I
mean the education system has gotten
worse in this country I know that and so
I would imagine that when she went to
school the education system was probably
a bit stronger so I would expect better
from her share we're going with the D
I'm sorry this isn't too bad it's sad
I'll give her a B just because you are
well-loved share your cruise great
legendary Chrissy Teigen it's Twitter
different or did I accidentally click on
old lady mode I felt that I'll tell you
what you clicked on old lady mode for
the way that you wrote this this is like
the way that my great-grandma might
tweet this is actually pretty good again
I don't know how they're not
capitalizing that I I feel like that
shouldn't happen automatically Twitter
is a proper noun come on Chrissy but you
know what I dig it I like the question I
like her asking the you know the
important questions and admitting that
she's kind of an old lady when it comes
to this technology stuff so you know
what for honesty we're going with the
solid B Chrissy I would I'd give her a -
Jaden Smith okay so this is one of my
biggest pet peeves is capitalizing the
first letter of every single word I
don't even want to read it but I'm going
to the only thing he could do that was
worse would be capitalizing every other
letter if everybody in the world dropped
out of school we would have a much more
intelligent society whoo those are
fighting words for a lot of people a
whole shade and honey
can we just like delete somebody's
Twitter account he has the opposite of
the other problem that I've mentioned
where he is capitalizing almost
everything which I guess is slightly
better than capitalizing every letter so
that you're like shouting but I'm just
gonna go ahead and uncapitalized
because this is egregious Jaden if you
want to know what the word egregious is
catch me in class I'll teach you so the
only thing that I think is really an
issue would be the capitalization and
that comma to separate the first and
second part of his sentences we're going
F - whenever you have two independent
clauses that function as their own
sentences you would need a word like
then anytime that you have that if you
must also have that then that's
something that you learn in school maybe
you've heard of it I'm gonna give Jaden
a B Donald Trump oh dear
everyone knows I am right that Robert
Pattinson should dump Kristen Stewart
this is already educational in a couple
years he will thank me be smart Robert
yeah you didn't make any really any
egregious errors here I mean I would you
know if I were being a stickler and
we're talking style and stuff which is
one of my things I would put it that
there well of course embarrassing that
the man who is now our president is
tweeting about celebrity teenage
relationships it's not new that he
thinks he's right about everything but
actually there aren't any errors that I
see this was in 2012 all right so it's
been seven years do we know if he
thanked him Robert Pattinson have you
thanked Donald Trump maybe if you think
him then things would get better Robert
I unfortunately as much as it pains me I
have to give this an A I definitely had
students who I didn't agree with but did
things right and I still gave them the
grades they deserves giving them a w and
it's not for win it's because that's
like almost the last letter you could
possibly give someone creating a new
grading system Christopher I feel like
there's a giant mutant inside of me I
hope she ate meatloaf otherwise the
explanation for this is very interesting
is she talking about the singer because
if so then that should be capitalized I
think we all have a giant meatloaf
inside of us just wanting to sing like
our life's a musical but Chris I don't
know if I believe you need to put a
period there
all she did here was not put a period at
the end and it makes me wonder if
there's more she had to say but she got
overcome with the meatloaf thing and
couldn't say anything else I guess an
a-minus just for the missing punctuation
if she's talking about the dinner food
then maybe she ate one I don't know
give her a C I think she did a good job
but she could have done better I think
Twitter is an interesting platform
because it gives us more instant access
to celebrities brains that we wouldn't
normally see and it's unedited and
probably much to the chagrin of many
publicists I think that social media has
been terrible for Grammer people should
aspire to be a little bit better with
the way that they write and speak it's
funny just to get a little slice of life
in the moment of someone who you kind of
think you know a little bit about from
their public persona and then you know
just thinking well the next time I'm
wondering about meatloaf I might think
of how Kris Jenner and I have something
in common
[Music]
you
[Music]